JOEL LEWIS: Hi, welcome
back to recitation.
In lecture, Professor
Miller did a bunch
of examples of
integrals involving
trigonometric functions.
So I thought I would
give you a couple more,
well I guess three more
examples, some of them
are a little different
flavor than the ones he did,
but some nice examples of some
integrals you can compute now.
One thing you might
need for them is you're
going to have to remember
some of your trig identities.
Just like you had to remember
some of them last time.
So in particular, one identity
that you might need today
that you didn't need in lecture,
was the angle sum identity
for cosine.
So let me just
remind you what that
is, it says the
cosine of a plus b
is equal to cosine a cosine
b minus sine a sine b.
So you're going to
need that formula
to compute one of
these three integrals.
So why don't you
pause the video,
take some time to
work these out.
Come back you can check your
answers against my work.
Hopefully you had
some fun and some luck
working on these integrals.
Let's have a go at them.
The first integral is sine
cubed x secant squared x.
So I don't think
that Professor Miller
did any integrals that
involved the secant function,
but one thing to remember is
that the secant function is
very closely related
to the cosine function.
It's just cosine to the minus 1.
Sorry, by that I mean 1 over
cosine, not the arccosine.
So, in order to--
so we can view this
first integral here
as an integral of a power of
sine times a power of cosine,
just like the ones
you had in lecture.
So we can write this as
sine cubed of x times--
I'm going to write cosine
x to the minus 2 dx.
And here we see this is a nice
example where the sine occurs
with an odd power.
So when the sine occurs with an
odd power, or when one of them
at least occurs
with an odd power,
life is relatively simple.
And what we do is
just what we did
in lecture, which is we
break it up so that we just
have one instance of the one
that occurs to an odd power
and then a bunch of
powers of the other one.
So in this case, we have
sine to an odd power.
So we want to pull
out all the even,
you know, all the extra
multiples, so in this case
we have sine times sine squared.
So we take all
those sine squareds
and we convert them into
1 minus cosine squareds.
This is going to be equal to the
integral of sine x times, well,
times sine squared x,
which is 1 minus cosine
squared x, times cosine x to
the minus second power dx.
And now you take
all these cosines
and you multiply them together
and you see what you've got.
So in this case that's
equal to the integral-- OK,
so 1 times cosine to the minus
2 is just cosine to the minus 2.
So this first term is
cosine x to the minus 2
sine x and then minus--
OK, we have cosine
squared times cosine
to the minus 2,
so that one's even simpler,
that's just minus sine x dx.
So at this point,
if you like, you
could do a substitution of
a trigonometric function.
You could set u
equal to cosine x.
All right?
What's going to
happen if you set
u equal to cosine x, well du
is going to be minus sine x dx.
Each of these have exactly one
appearance of sine x in them,
so this would become-- so
if we set u equal cosine x.
So, as I said du
equals minus sine x dx.
Because each of these
have a sine x dx in them,
that's going to get
clumped into the du.
And the cosines will just get
replaced with u everywhere.
So I'm going to
take this over here
so I have a little more space.
So this becomes the integral
of u to the minus 2,
I guess it's minus u to
the minus 2 plus 1 du.
That minus sine x is
just exactly equal to du.
OK.
And now this is easy
to finish from here.
This is equal to,
well OK, so minus 2,
so we have to go
up one to minus 1,
so that's just u to the
minus 1, plus 1 gives us
a u, plus a constant,
and then of course we
have to substitute back in.
So this is u is cosine
x, so u to the minus 1
is secant x plus cosine
x plus a constant.
So that's the first one.
For the second one,
sine x cosine of 2x.
We actually have a slightly
more complicated situation here.
Because the cosine
2x is no longer,
it's not just a trigonometric
function of x alone,
it's a trigonometric
function of 2x.
So in order to do the sort of
the things we did in lecture,
what you're going
to have to do is,
you're going to have to expand
this out in terms of just sine
x and cosine x, rather
than cosine of 2x.
So in order to do that
you just need to remember
your double angle formula.
Now if you don't remember
your double angle formulas,
one way you can remember them is
remember the angle sum formula
and apply it with a
and b both equal to x.
If you like.
But, or you could just remember
your double angle formulas.
So let's go over here.
And so in this case, we have
the integral of sine x times,
well cosine 2x-- so there
are actually, right,
there are several different
ways you can write cosine 2x.
So one way you can write it
is cosine squared x minus sine
squared x, but we want
everything-- again
we have an odd power of
sine, so it would be nice
if everything else
could be written
in terms of just cosine.
So an equivalent form for
cosine 2x is to write,
is that it's equal to 2
cosine squared x minus 1 dx.
And here, this is very, very
similar to the last question.
Again, you can make the
substitution u equals cosine,
if you like.
And so I'm not going to do out
the whole substitution for you,
but this is going to work out
to 2 cosine squared x sine
x, the integral of that is minus
2/3 cosine cubed x and then
the integral of minus
sine x is cosine x
plus a constant of integration.
So that's the second one.
The third one now is
of a similar flavor,
except you have here, you
have sine 2x and cosine 3x.
So again, when you want
to integrate something
where you have-- so here we have
both trigonometric functions
occur in multiples.
Now, if it was
the same multiple,
if it were 2x and 2x,
say, that would be fine.
You know, you could
just make a substitution
like u equals 2x or something
and then proceed as usual.
But because they're
different multiples,
we need, when we do
these trig integrals,
we need to apply the methods
that we used in lecture.
You want the arguments to agree.
So you want it all to be
sine of something and cosine
of the same thing.
So here the thing
to do, I think,
is to try and put
everything in terms
of just sine x and cosine x.
So sine 2x is one you should
remember, double angle formula.
Cosine 3x, well in order to
figure out what cosine 3x is,
you could just
know it, maybe you
learned it once upon a time.
The other thing you
can do for cosine 3x,
is you can use this
angle sum formula.
So let me just work that
out for you quickly.
So cosine of 3x, well how do
you use the angle sum formula?
You can write 3x as 2x plus x.
So this is equal to
cosine of 2x plus x.
And now this is a sum, so you
can use the cosine sum formula,
so you get this is equal to
cosine 2x cosine x minus sine
2x sine x.
OK and now you can use
the double angle formulas
here and here.
so in the end, if you
do this all out, what
you get is you're
going to get 4 cosine
cubed x minus 3 cosine x.
You might say, oh what
happened to the sine x's?
We're going to get
a sine squared x
and I want to write
everything in terms of cosine.
So I've replaced the-- I've
done an extra step here
that I'm not showing,
where I replaced
the sine squared x with a
1 minus cosine squared x.
So you make this
substitution, and you also
make the substitution
for sine x-- sorry,
for sine 2x that you have.
OK, sine 2x is equal to-- you
know, double angle formula--
2 sine x cosine x.
And so when you multiply
sine 2x by cosine 3x
you again have an expression
that's got powers of cosine
with a single power of sine.
So doing these simplifications,
you again get this nice form.
One of them's odd,
the other one-- one
of the trig functions,
sine or cosine
appears to just the
power of 1, so, OK,
so you can do this nice
simple substitution.
You don't need to do any of
the double angle, or half angle
complication.
I'm not going to finish
this one out for you,
but I did write down the answer
so you can check your answer.
When you-- the third
integral that we had,
which is integral sine 2x
cosine 3x dx, when you work it
all out you should get,
let's see what I got, OK,
you should get minus 8/5
cosine to the fifth x
plus 2 cosine cubed x plus
a constant of integration.
So if you work out
all the details,
this is what you should get.
I'll stop there.